mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
a b is a chord of the circle x squared
plus y squared is equal to 16.
the tangents at a and b meet at c
if m at one comma two is the midpoint of
a b
then what is the area of the kite oacb
o is the origin located at zero comma
zero
i thank nilesh for the suggestion this
problem is adapted from a test in india
called the jee mains
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll get started by sketching the graph
x squared plus y squared is equal to 16
is a circle with a radius of four that's
centered at the origin zero comma zero
we have the point m at one comma two
which is the midpoint of the chord a b
we draw tangents at a and b
to meet at a point c
we then connect o a and ob which each
have a length of four
we want to calculate the area of this
kite
to get started we'll draw om
we can calculate the length of om using
the distance formula
om will have a length equal to the
square root of 1 squared plus 2 squared
which will be equal to the square root
of 5.
we then will extend mc so that oc is the
other diagonal of the kite
let's now just focus on the kite the
diagonals meet at right angles and the
tangents to the circle also are at right
angles
so how can we calculate the area of this
kite
we'll first calculate the length of am
we can do that using the gogo theorem
am will be equal to the square root of 4
squared minus the square root of 5
squared and this will simplify to be the
square root of 11.
from here we'll use similar triangles
triangle aom is similar to triangle coa
therefore we have that ao divided by om
this will be 4 over the square root of 5
is equal to co divided by oa
therefore we can solve for co it'll be
equal to 16 divided by the square root
of five
from here we can calculate the area of
the kite
it'll be equal to twice the area of this
triangle
and we can calculate the area of this
triangle because it has a base of 16
divided by the square root of 5 and it
has a height equal to the square root of
11.
we substitute that in the area of a
triangle is equal to one-half its base
times its height and we get the area of
the kite is equal to 16 multiplied by
the square root of 11 over the square
root of 5 and that's approximately 23.73
and that's the answer
it was a very intimidating problem but
once we sketched the graph and worked
step by step we were able to figure it
out
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you